il faut que je sois mieux s'informer
mais c'est vrai que
j'ai peur que ça soit une fausse une
fausse élections et qu'on qu'on nous
conduisent vers un candidat prêt choisir
en mettant d'autres non candidat juste à
côté
dont on ne saurait rien qu'elles sont
par exemple pour les verts qu'est ce qui
est en dehors de shadow peut-être des
inconnus et dont je vais choisir qui pas
un inconnu dont je vais subodorer qui va
avoir très peu de de pourcentage de voix
donc j'ai choisir le gros candidat ce
sera en fait un bon choix on va me
donner l'illusion de la démocratie
oui c'est très intéressant ça permet de
re découvrir un peu plus sur chaque bord
6 et de découvrir un peu ce que tout le
monde proposé de pouvoir se forger un
avis plus constructif j'ai déjà voté
pour oui j'ai déjà voté et puis je suis
prêt à le refaire aussi si c'est pour
aider si c'est pour construire quelque
chose de meilleur oui bien sûr c'est
intéressant il ya là plusieurs il vaut
mieux qu'il ya une seule personne qui ce
qui représente son parti toute enquête
moi je participerai j'ai déjà participé
mais je pense que je participerai pru
pas ce que c'est c'est pas très efficace
le pense donc je préfère que les parties
se débrouille en interne pour trouver un
candidat honnêtement on sait très bien
que les petits bus et des petits
programmes des partis vont pas vont pas
passer donc au final ça va être les
mêmes candidats avec les mêmes
programmes comme il ya tous les cinq ans
donc finalement on se laissent un peu
porter et puis et puis on retrouve les
mêmes quantités à mainstream des
primaires j'ai tendance à penser pour
les parties je sais pas pourquoi sur les
dernières élections c'est un peu une
machine élire le plus mauvais candidat
donc sais pas si c'est forcément une
bonne idée pour les partis mais après
pour légitimer les candidats je pense
que c'est franchement ce que c'est une
bonne chose pas trop non pas trop à
droite j'ai vu que j'étais pécresse
contre
bertrand veut dire qu'on va pas faire la
prière donc on sait pas comment ça va
passer au niveau de la droite au niveau
de la gauche montebourg il veut pas ça
veut pas passer par les primaires donc
il ya les écologistes s'ils conservent
dans leurs côtés donc chacun peut-être
s'extirper entre eux et puis il va pas
rester grand chose quoi il risque de
laisser des séquelles des blessures dans
chacun de leurs partis l'intérêt des
primaires peut-être c'est de découvrir
ou mieux connaître des gens qui ne sont
pas devenus des vedettes politiques qui
peuvent représenter un point de vue
intéressant je pense à la primaire de la
droite 2016 de l'automne 2016 ou par
exemple quelqu'un comme jean frédéric
poisson s'est fait connaître